we've got a lot of news to get to this
morning we're going to start with this
the big story dozens of Boeing's newest
model 737 Jets will carry passengers
around the United States today despite
growing pressure from lawmakers to stop
flying them but airlines and at least 15
other countries and territories have
grounded those max series planes after
Sunday's deadly crash in Ethiopia
it was the second accident involving a
max 8 Southwest American and United are
the only US airlines that operate the
737 max they say they are sticking with
the aircraft the Ethiopian Airlines max
8 that crashed killing 157 people is the
same model as a jet that went down in
Indonesia last fall Kris Van Cleave is
at Washington's Reagan National Airport
with the increasing concern over that
plane Chris good morning to you good
morning pressure is really mounting on
the FAA this morning two Democratic
senators Dianne Feinstein and Richard
Blumenthal are now calling for the
agency to ground all of the maxes in the
u.s. during this investigation still
tens of thousands of people a day fly on
the 72 max jets that are being operated
here in the United States the airlines
say they're safe customers are starting
to worry as investigators scramble to
find out what happened onboard Ethiopian
Airlines flight 302 the second Boeing
737 max eight to crash in less than five
months many airlines are grounding their
Mac's fleets Aeromexico and Aero
leanness Argentina's are among the
latest of more than two dozen carriers
to temporarily stop flying the Macs in
the u.s. Southwest and American Airlines
which operate two of the largest 737 max
eight fleets are still flying them the
United Airlines is continuing to operate
the longer 737 max nine in an update to
Airlines the FAA says it does not have
enough data from Sunday's crash to take
action yet but will if the investigation
indicates the need to do so on Monday
flight attendants unions pushed back
against the FAA and the airline's we
need to hear from the FAA with
transparency here about what steps
they're taking to address the concerns
of the public and the crews who are
working on these planes some passengers
are worried too I am looking at making
sure that I'm not going to put myself on
a 737 said a little prayer and
got here see one woman asked Southwest
on Twitter how to find out what plane
she's traveling on for a flight in May
saying she doesn't want to fly on a 737
max Southwest responded stressing the
safety of its operation saying it had no
plans to stop operating its max jets
Ross Hamer is a retired airline captain
who flew an older version of the 737 we
don't know exactly if this is the same
thing that happened a few months ago
with the lion air
he says the data and voice recorders
recovered from flight 302 need to be
analyzed before US airlines take any
action perhaps a grounding may be a
right thing to do till we found out
exactly what happened and and Boeing
comes up with a fix now Boeing CEO says
he is confident in the safety of the 737
max the company says it is working to
understand all aspects of Sunday's
tragic accident the FAA tells CBS News
it is anticipating new regulations to
require some design changes to the 737
max that includes a software update
but that stems from the previous deadly
accident with the max not the Ethiopia
crash Gale Chris I tell you it's all
very disconcerting I'm flying this
weekend I first thing I asked the travel
agent is is it a max eight plane is that
a question a we should be asking and
number two what about people who want to
change their tickets if they've already
been booked on one of those those max
eight planes well it's a question a lot
of people are asking and the way to find
out you can call your airline you can
look in your reservation email that
usually tells you the aircraft type and
certainly it is online
none of the US airlines are waiving
change fees though so if you want to
make a change to get off of a max plane
it may cost you some money I'll tell you
Gail I flew on one on Friday the US
airlines insist they are safe all right
Chris thank you very much